to GameSpot's continuing coverage of the
electronic triple 2014 we are nearly
done only two appointments left two
guests right here on the game sports a
Jew I'm delighted to be joined by Kevin
Doyle I'm in a name it's possibly more
Irish than mine possibly your community
manager for black gold online that's
right snail you guys are based over in
China is like Rovio based out of Sioux
Joe and the jhansi Province in China and
we also have a satellite office in Santa
Monica here in a global operation
absolutely I like it and probably
fitting considering you are a part of
your one of those studios building
entirely new worlds and I remember
actually I believe month this stage
specifically was with 20 feet that way
but I was at talking to one of you guys
about black all online last year you
guys are pretty close stuck to our
actual launch we are in fact actually so
here at e3 were actually showcasing a
lot of new things coming out from the
snail games office but the centerpiece
of all that is black gold online which
will be coming into open beta on jun
20th and to sort of get ready for that
we actually have some special goodies i
have my my steampunk black gold online
top hat to show us pretty rad and also i
wanted to introduce in addition to
myself we have our own special guests
here this is a priest wilcox this is our
flat family you want a virtual contest
to join us here at e3 so coming tonight
come on me to say hello to say hello to
Maurice what's his name marie therese
Wilcox hey Maurice were so glad you
could join us here in Los antes where's
he lived somewhere down south I forget
okay so we're ready to feel bad about
that some more we would have been we
would have Brooklyn there they go they
go Maurice you're right here Maurice
Maurice has never been inside up oh yeah
that would Daniel Dwyer I feel like I
know you can claim that honor not many
can I have any of these hands you got it
like we've got a lot still giving away
in our booth and all the leftovers will
be given away through some community
programs will be running out of our own
office but we also got a few I think
five or six that we've been given over
to GameSpot's you give out at their
lastic thank you very much will I will
find somewhere some nice Twitter homes
for those bad boys absolutely all right
let's get into the meat of a black hole
online is an MMO I feel like these games
that live and die on the specifics and
so let's let's talk about it you got
absolutely appears my code on line is a
fantasy steampunk crossover MMORPGs so
it takes place in this fantasy world
called Montell which is split between in
the East something called Vickie lenders
Union which is a basically a series of
races that are filled magic and
elemental fantasy and sorcery and
mythical beasts and to the west kingdom
isin horse which is more steampunk
neo-victorian mixed with spaghetti
westerns and they ride into battle on
these giant walking and flying
mechanical monstrosities and are both
these cultures kind of odds with each
other absolutely so for most of the
backstory of the game for a long time
they were completely separate and then
recently they have discovered each other
now when players enter the game they are
basically on the edge of all-out war so
they're at war over the namesake of the
game this resource called black gold is
this powerful elemental energy crystal
which the kingdom of isin horse uses as
the foundation of their industry they
burned it as a fuel and the Year an
Islander Union uses it as the foundation
their magic they worship it they chant
around it to channel elemental energy in
the form of fire and water and wind
magic you don't have to stretch too far
into geopolitics to see some sort of
metaphor in there as well absolutely
east and west over restored it's
basically the game is about a more over
territory in a war over resources
between two totally different worlds
they're completely opposite on an
artistic level and in a conceptual level
of their gameplay they're totally
different and one of the things about
mmos that I've sort of as earthed me a
bit in the past number of years is that
maybe five or six years ago whatever you
joined one faction you had to play a
certain way whenever you joined another
faction here to play a different way
we've seen this sort of homogeny of many
but that's sort of like faction v
faction stuff where hey you know what if
you want to be that guy from that side
on this side it's okay how how like
defiantly are you splitting the two
cultures in black goes well there's a
couple things about that so for one
thing there are factional e specific
classes so at the moment for open beta
which again goes into goes open on jun
20th we're gonna have four playable
races two for each faction in six play
or twelve playable classes 64 each
faction at full release which is coming
later in the year we'll have six races
and 18 classes okay and those will be
faction Utley specific though for the
open beta we are allowing a few
crossover classes classes you can play
for you know maybe a fan ec class but
you really like the way it plays and you
want to be on the steampunk side all the
different classes have really unique
abilities but they also parallel systems
so there
are people who are more sort of like off
tanks and people were more like healers
but all the different classes blur those
lines of your typical tanking dpsing and
healing sort of roles that you'd play in
the typical MMORPG cool on top of that
in addition to our basic combat we also
have mounted combat we have no straddle
carriers which you basically create and
build over time and those are distinct
for each of the two factions again they
are parallel in terms of their structure
but you have sort of walking already on
the screen giant you know monstrosities
on the year these are sort of black gold
mutated creatures for ill endure and on
the isin were side you have these
walking mechanize yeah machine I was
getting a kind of an unreal tournament
2005 vibe off of some of the mounts on
the other side see you said there you
actually build and improve them over
time is yeah are the mount sort of in
that way like personalized to you a bit
they are they are to a certain extent
personalized so you do create them
throughout different activities in the
game there's actually over a hundred
different carriers you can get in the
game and you choose yourself how you
upgrade them and develop them along
different development lines and they're
yours they take persistent damage they
have their own attacks and their own
health bar and if they get destroyed
then they're destroyed and you have to
you have to really take care of them
make sure they use them appropriately
awesome okay let's talk about the
moment-to-moment action we're seeing
here and to me this is looking very very
much on at least a superficial level
like many mmos I played in the past so
explain some of this sort of what they
makes black well yes you can it's one
thing you see we're kind of in this
video switching in and out of using our
battle carriers which is really one of
the things that makes black or online
stand out there aren't really any other
MMOs that have this level of mounted
combat we have regular mounts for
transportation in addition but we have
all these carriers that you can use for
mounted combat in addition our actual
combat system itself is a very
action-oriented it's not your typical
tab targeted you see a lot of MMOs it
requires a lot of aiming and a lot of
dodging so it kind of mixes together
these kind of slash them up and also
like range casting and also sort of some
FPS in the terms of the way you use the
carrier's so that is a really unique
feature alongside the really unique art
style of clashing between steampunk on
the one side and fantasy on the other so
the combat definitely seems to be a
focus as you just alluded to there PvP
is a huge part of this game it's you
exclusively PvP we have tons of things
like instanced dungeons you're sort of
battle ground slopes though battlefields
that you can also participate in there
sort of rolling battlefields everybody
can participate in we also have certain
cool guild competition end game features
both energy wells that have their own
type of mounted and unmounted back can
we talk about those a bit i saw
something down in a trailer recently in
a fan it looked pretty interesting so
the energy wells are these pieces of the
map that the whole map is actually
divided up into little chunks that can
be captured in control they all have
their own fortresses that'll call these
energy wells that are sort of reservoirs
of black gold that will give certain
benefits to those people who control
them so every week there's a factional
war between ear linder and eyes and
[ __ ] yeah to capture for your factions
certain parts of the map for these
energy wells the rest of the week after
that all of the guilds of that faction
will then fight amongst themselves for
personal control ok so you're kind of
teaming up on Saturday and then Angeles
throats on a Monday I try to get
personal control of these and there's a
lot of really great political
backstabbing and negotiations in terms
of diplomacy of teams building you know
teaming up to take on more powerful
guilds and capturing these energy wells
to get special instances special daily
quests and also a daily reward of black
goal which they have to distribute
amongst their guild mates in order to
use them so how much of the overall map
involves that type of territory battling
well the entire map is actually a huge
explorable map we still have some areas
that are up for under construction that
will come out for the full release
wouldn't be a beta otherwise exactly but
for the open beta you can pretty much
walk from one edge of the map to the
other completely on your own that's
completely open explorable world and
really every single whip area has some
kind of energy well territorial dispute
and so as we expand the map will build
more energy wells to make that creature
even more integrated in this cool I'm
assuming both factions of some sort of a
home hub area is absolutely so the
further to east and west that you get on
the map the more distinct the art
concept and the environment will be so
today we actually see on the map where
in the south west of isin horse and so
it's really this kind of barren
wasteland desert you see it's very you
know it's actually so this is are the
ruins where one of the expansion classes
or when expansion races will be adding
into the full release the u.p rhian
vampire where they're going to live but
as you also then get towards the center
you see there's more contested regions
where
you see maybe like tribal totems right
next to little little you know
cobblestone streets as the juice style
is kind of intermix and juxtapose so
each race has their own distinct
storyline that as you go through there's
special quests that you do particular to
each race you start out in different us
or home home worlds and and that is
where that goes from you can also see
this is a little example of our skill
tree where each class has their own
distinct skills that can kind of
intermix so players can really customize
in terms of racially in terms of how
what kind of carriers they get and also
in terms of what kind of skills they use
in a daily hole and in their day-to-day
combat as you talked a lot about the PvP
stuff and I want to talk to you about
questing yeah as well when I was playing
a lot of MMOs in the past one of my most
favorite part was getting lost on my own
away from the idea of interacting with
other people and sometimes it just broke
immersion a little bit too much if we
talk about questing it's something of a
known quantity in a lot of MMOs now it
is the go find you know go kick five
chickens or go pick up ten ruined pelt
it's raining you guys are trying to do a
quest had to do something to break new
ground in terms of our actual gameplay
so the quests are one part of the
general leveling grind that you can
participate in some really the way we
see it is the quests are more to reveal
the story of the game because in
addition to these major factions there
are a lot of really interesting sub back
shins going on we have sort of these is
there's a cult that's trying to bring
about the end of the world and there's
also rogue genetic mutation scientists
and things like that and these are sort
of sub antagonists to sort of plague you
throughout the the game as you explore
the world and see more of it also the
role of the quest is to introduce new
game features to you so as you level up
and go through these quests they
introduce the carrier system to you they
introduce the battlefield systems to you
they introduced what we call adventures
which are these cool mix of PvE and PvP
opt-in activities and once you reach the
point where you have discovered those
then you can actually freely participate
those and whenever you want to acquire
extra gems and extra gear and stuff like
that cool um but as you said also the
game is still in open beta so as we move
forward we're also looking to expand on
I'm more lab request lines as well and i
want to remind the folks home to have
any questions for kevin of a black gold
online athlon ii would wire on twitter
and i'll keep an eye on now i should
have said it earlier and but I have any
questions I'll i'll make sure to shoot
them all over ok so it seems like you
guys are doing a lot you've got the the
sort
the PvP stuff you've got the
battleground stuff you have the energy
wells as well for the black gold and
they're requesting as well what is the
general moment-to-moment play a black
hole online is there a lot of farming is
there a lot of exploration like what
would you say is the one thing that
you'll probably be what's what's driving
you in black hole online well really
what's driving you in the game as far as
the way we tried to build in the the
motivation behind any player is greed in
this world where the two factions are
fighting over territory fighting over
resources and those resources becoming
increasingly scarce you're kind of out
for yourself and whether you band with
your faction band with your guild or
just play by yourself you're always
looking to protect yourself in that way
so there's a lot of for one thing open
exploration trying to find new things
new we have open world of dynamic events
called outbreaks they just pop up
randomly check behind those so you can
get special points and special gear for
that trying to go into instance dungeons
with other teammates in order to get
high level gear just exploring the map
to see what other kind of cool things
that are out there and then also
participating in these rolling battles
both open world PvP against other
players in the middle of the map and
then also these structured mounted
battlefields a variety seems to be the
really it's occasions you a bunch of
different things over time depending on
what you want to do so they're also as a
crafting system like you mentioned and
it is something you can also so you
don't actually even have to do the PvP
if you don't want to that's not your
style there's also plenty of PvE to do
and there's also a crafting system where
you can create your own equipment and
the crafting system requires a lot of
teamwork because you only get one
profession and the different professions
have to work together to create higher
level gear okay so ask for collaboration
is sort of key in that respect that'll
you have to find we have an internal
auction house that should look this is
straight out of under the tournament
2005 I love it I'm not saying you guys
ripped it off I'm saying I like where
you're going with this exactly we got
all these different carriers some of
them can fly there's actually five
classes of these battle carries this is
an example of the aerial one so each of
the different carriers has advantages
and disadvantages so there's like a
rock-paper-scissors assortment so none
of them are on top so there's aerials
are flying with assault which are really
heavy duty against other carriers but
weak against aerials and then we have an
anti-air which is really weak against
the assault but very powerful against
the aerial and then there's other ones
such as raid for hunting down
players on the ground and siege for
during those energy well battles
besieging enemy fortresses like knocking
down walls destroying turrets and even
sometimes you can acquire bosses that
would protect your fortress for you it's
easier to take those on if you have the
siege carriers available so it requires
arting to be a team work as you as you
strategize bringing out what your
strengths are and what your weaknesses
are trying to win those battlefields
sweet i got time for one more question
when I throw this one after Stuart
Hopkins on Twitter he's asked is there a
subscription model in place for this or
is it some free like Guild Wars what's
your model for this it is totally free
to play game so at the moment the
download is already available for the
June twentieth beta and we actually also
have we want to plug a special early
access character creation section
because we have a very it's are
internally developed into game engine
called some flexi it's called something
great something awesome you got out
flexi and it's a very intense very
integrated career recreation systems
will get people the opportunity to get
in the game reserve their name and pre
make their characters we also have a
retail box edition available with some
of our partners at gamestop amazon best
buy and several others those are
available for pre-order with our
official content available for people
who order that and it's completely free
to play so you don't have to pay a dime
it's an entirely optional monetization
model we're essentially in addition to
open world loot that you can get on your
own there's special ways that you can
get extra loop by earning it through
special quest that you can do and then
you can purchase extra stuff on the side
from get from doing wait Kevin Doyle
thank you very much today Michael online
pleasure to have you here can i wear the
hospital right ticket legs really
appreciate it and we're gonna be back
with plants vs zombies later